we are joined by the good place and it's
kind of a good place because they're all
here and it's kind of a sad place
because it's the end of an era well not
till September it starts but then it's
gonna be the end of the show and people
love it and are you ready to say goodbye
this is weird we are not ready to say
goodbye and it is weird
yeah yeah a little bit mad at make sure
he said I have to end the show but then
when he told us why and how and the what
of it all we were like oh yeah that's
the right ending and so there's it's
it's the best worst feeling you could
have because we don't want to leave each
other we really like having the purpose
of this show
yeah like funny things but also how to
be a good person you know we also know
that this is the right move and it's
satisfying so at the end of this all do
your characters deserve to be in a good
place
how do you know we're in the good yeah
what are you talking about what do you
think you know who are you
I do things on that journey i I mean I I
feel like it's got to be a happy ending
ready it's incredibly satisfying and
he's so satisfied yes it's a very
interesting thought-provoking ending
yeah okay well I feel like we're in a
very good place because of the big emmy
nomination for the whole like well
you've been nominated solo before but
the whole show now yeah you know how
long it is right but this is so excited
is amazing does it mean to sort of go
out with a bang like this and be able to
celebrate the show in a big way at the
Emmys what we really hope for is that
Mike Schur gets to stand up and receive
the acknowledgment he deserves as far as
we're concerned yeah yeah we love our
daddy good yeah yeah I'm watching him
get a standing ovation from 7,000 people
today with just felt like the most
wonderful thing to experience because
he's such a genius I love this and
Kristen you're in a good place because
you met Lynn
he's still shaking I was okay I'm okay
now I was super excited and then I was
very very excited it starts I can't
really find the words I love him so much
not just because of the content that he
makes and the brilliant mind he is but
because of what he pumps out into the
universe it's like I just think he
should be in charge of earth he and Mike
really to be honest and fix it yeah we
wanted to say was I love you so much in
like what should I do
marching orders from the herd I can I do
anything for you listen you did do
something and it changed your profile
pic well hash tag new profile pic anyway
didn't he change his perfect person I'm
gonna probably take my dog to guys I'm
gonna be like we heard what is Dax thing
des loves it he immediately texted me
how excited he was and I posted the
picture and then he said something funny
I don't know some sort of word no more
confident manner than Shepard right he's
always yeah he's always yelling get some
honey so he it was very that's true
whenever they kiss on in on the show
he's thanks get to go yeah look we're
married not buried thank you
that's the reality
I love this okay so what is the craziest
thing that you have had to do to protect
spoilers on the show
oh really always love him in during
hiatus can you just not keep it in why
it's like a contract that he loves good
news it is raining
yeah messenger yeah it's hard to I mean
it's why sorry I was just gonna say that
it's why Mike didn't send us the finale
on
he was gonna send it to us last night
and he didn't this guy yeah he was
worried Ted would slip up at the panel
final season do you think we're gonna
marry possibly a Dax cameo has been on
it remember he was a member of the bad
place right so it's done Mary whatever
Mary comes to set we're very very happy
we always swarmer yeah we try to get her
attention okay so it came out like I
don't know like five hours ago but who's
like finished the hall Veronica Mars yet
because we've all been together so none
of us we I'm I don't want to hear
feedback from anyone yet okay too soon
yes you soon it's only been 12 hours
easy like that yes I was here all day
yesterday it's why I look so fatigued
today it's why I wear this bright color
to dismiss on other guys on that show
more than Karen
that's why I love the men in my life
right everyone's like kissed we are only
monkeys guys okay you're allowed to be
attracted to more than one person is a
good place sorry I want to ask you about
your new show you're coming up with Tina
Fey there's a lot of buzz wrong what are
you gonna tell us can you tease I'm not
telling you squat I'm the mayor of LA
okay that's all I know
truly that's all I know and it's a lot I
did read a script but it's you know I'm
a
and it's a lot more than mike short told
us he didn't we have to sign on with
Mike before without even reading
anything he's that kind of guy well at
least he told you what the show was
about he didn't tell us what the show
was even about who we were playing so I
was worried it was gonna be Mike's first
pornos what we were signing up before
thank heavens it wasn't thank heaven
Yeah right
hasn't been yet it's not much anyway
your expectations out of the water from
what you signed on for I don't know what
I could possibly ever do after this
because I don't know what can ever
compare to working with Mike and with
all of these people I'm retiring I'm
announcing it now it's very good place
text chain we talked about food trucks a
lot food truck is coming what snacks or
people are gonna get the users will
responds to things with like nonsensical
like just a lot of letters and caps and
I'm going remind me again what a meme is
very right I like I could see the snap
thing because you guys came in and we
have some snacks that right you went
right to the guac well at the
Entertainment Tonight walk which is
pretty smooth it's very good okay last
thing um can I get an update on bad
grandmas if I had when I'd give it to
you I would be loose lipped just like
Ted I have any updates though nothing no
crawl up do you make movies this is the
busiest woman in Hollywood one time I
interview her on set and she was eating
a salad while I was asking the questions
and then being like a question giver
during her time this woman I mean you
know this season she not only acted on
the show but also directed that's not to
tasking man how was that it was great it
was great
ask us how yeah what did you think it
was by her for a reason right because
normally I'm just bossing everyone
around but now I actually had a reason
to and they had to
this time and no it was wonderful Mike
gave me a great opportunity and he was
very encouraging and I it wasn't
something I thought I would seek out but
he sort of primed me for it and I was I
take his advice and so I was like oh if
you think I should do this then yeah I
will try to stretch my wings and it was
a wonderful experience because everyone
knows what they're doing perfect place
to try it out and I had a great time too
much humility do it again hmm
it was it's the best episode and you'll
never see anything like it again yeah no
you don't like that uh you don't have
time to do more directing but could you
is this something that could be more in
the future maybe yeah maybe on shows
that I know and love I couldn't imagine
just taking on a project that I didn't
know and love but if Mike were to ask me
to do it again yes I would well
congratulations we'll see you guys at
the Emmys
yeah yeah gratulations there is a season
five you heard it here good place picked
up for 17 more season
[Music]